[Music]
diego starts us off in phoenix arizona
hi diego welcome to the ramsay show
hey dave how are you guys doing today
better than i deserve what's up
hi so um i'm 26 i have my bachelor's i
want to go to medical school i want to
do a debt free i've heard you talk about
it before on the show to go through like
the military
see like what other programs that they
offer
um i tried going through them i got
disqualified um so i like i don't i
really like don't want to go into all
this debt but like it's just so time
consuming and on top of that i live with
my parents like i'm 26 like i want to
move out but but it seems like like i
don't know how i can do it without going
into debt you know because i want to go
to medical school like i'm ready to go
like i'm going to do this masters um
in august that that will give me a an
entryway into medical school so it's
just like a nine month
master's program but to do that i need
to go into all this debt so i like i
don't know i don't know what what what i
could do you know
yeah diego it's a great question i feel
like
this is one we get
you know quite often especially whether
it's medical school or
law school and i think different
situations different schools have
different routes and of course it's a
very it's it's very rare and dave i
obviously would love your take on it
because you talk to people more than i
do with this scenario but
but what i know diego is that there have
been ways that people have found a way
not just to pay cash but they've done
things within the medical community or
they were part of
um you know
not not a fellowship but some type of
program that actually helps them pay
their way through and i feel like i hear
more often
that happening more in the law school
spectrum
but dave have you
for medical school specifically
um there's a couple of things that are
going on um number one i want to go back
and address the phrase you said this is
so time consuming let me tell you what's
time consuming paying off 250 000 in
debt that's time consuming
okay so yeah you need to spend the time
and and the effort and that is the big
deal is to spend the time and the effort
on the front end there's a couple of
angles i would tell you to look at
one is where you get accepted to medical
school is very very important in the
equation because medical school's not
unlike other forms of higher education
in that some of that is 4 and 5x what
the other one costs
and so you know there is the cheaper
version and by the way i don't remember
ever asking a doctor where he went to
school
i just asked him if he could fix that
broken thing on me you know that's all i
wanted to know
and so uh and if he convinced me he
could then we're there i never really
asked for credentials did you go to
uh you know
a big-time med school or a little-known
med school i didn't ask uh now obviously
uh you can learn some things in some
places you can't learn at other places
and those sorts of things but anyway so
school selection just like it is in
undergrad is very important the second
thing you can look for is the md phd
program
uh the most famous one is over at duke
but there are several schools around the
country that have those and that's
basically where you get on staff at the
school
and do some teaching some undergrad
teaching some grad level teach you know
grad level teaching type stuff like
graduate assistant type teaching and
since you're a staff member you get free
or near free tuition uh very it's like
getting a fellowship though it's very
rare it's very hard to get in
you know one in a hundred one in
whatever get it the second thing i would
do is i would pick up ramsey personality
uh christina ellis's book confessions of
a scholarship winner
what christina did was she managed to
apply for and get enough scholarships
that she got a half a million dollars in
scholarships
yeah she did yeah that'll pay for your
med school dude okay so you need to do
what she did in that sense because she
ended up going getting her undergrad and
then went to vanderbilt for her grad
paid cash for all of it had money left
over
uh and she's on our team now she's a
brand new ramsey personality but before
she came here she wrote a book that's a
was a bestseller called confessions of a
scholarship winner the secrets that
helped me win 500 000 in free money for
college how you can too so that that
type of stuff is the type of material
you need to be
rolling around in all day long the last
thing i will tell you and again this is
all just needle in a haystack stuff but
dude all you gotta do is find one
yeah and you're there you don't have to
this does not have to be a um
a policy for the united states of
america this is
diego just got to do it just diego
that's the only guy's got to do it all
right so for your sake anyway
now a lot of the large pharmaceutical
companies
and large hospital companies are
desperate to have doctors
like them
and that includes future doctors
and so they some of them have
scholarship or work for hire type
programs meaning that you can talk to a
large hospital corporation and promise
to work for them
in a different setting maybe at a
reduced rate for several years
but you know you can go to an
underserved area an inner city area a
rural area where they're having trouble
getting docks to park and you go there
and serve for three years afterwards you
get paid to do that but in return for
making that promise in advance it's a
modern day indentured servant program
you
you get free medical school paid for by
them so that's the type of stuff i'm
looking for is that all of that worth it
well you've just got to weigh it out but
i can tell you this
christina talks about she probably made
a thousand dollars an hour applying for
scholarships
so i mean if she had what 50 000 hours
you know in the thing so that'd be
that'd be a hundred dollars an hour you
know or five thousand hours would be a
would be a thousand dollars an hour that
she got and she's she's amazing oh yeah
i know christina's absolutely incredible
i don't know like the scholarships
in the medical yeah but these were not
tied to anything she used them for grad
no she did but i'm saying for diego yeah
uh how specific yeah like are they
specific for medical i don't know
they're very again anything this
graduate level is harder to get than
undergrad yes yes a lot of undergrad out
there laying around and so yeah you're
saying all this is a needle in haystack
and sure it is but
what i know is even being on this show
and talking to people around the country
people have done it like they'll come up
to me in a book signing line or
something like oh yeah i went to medical
school debt-free
yes i always ask because it's some kind
of program like this right it takes a
little bit of that creativity like when
debt is not an option in your life and
you said i'm not whether it's medical
school or credit card debt you have to
find a new way of looking it's not just
this automatic so it does take some
creativity but this is not work
it's not getting in the drive-through
and getting a starbucks right you're
gonna have to this is not cookie cutter
i mean there's not one on every corner
right you're gonna have to scratch and
claw and dig and turn over rocks until
the crawdad runs out you don't know what
that is but there you go i know what a
crawdad is i know he doesn't but diego
where's diego from phoenix no but
there's crawdads in phoenix you think i
don't know is there in louisiana they're
crayfish so i don't know